this is the ear scene hmm good stand
still living outer great um so hot
P me dim me oh my god
usually what I wanted will go like this
I want the rent if you still see the I
wait no you don't need a costumer which
I yeah
the way yeah perfect okay easy
well I'm back this is it no now why are
you battling me doing what I'm always
doing when you should be filming our
print out there oh yeah there's a brick
here get out there are too messy
alright the camera yeah prices oh this
sounds like a cereal
yeah hello foreigners are you okay being
filmed in the behind the scenes I was
just explaining that I'm wearing most
hilariously Britisher Oh cuz this is the
annoying hometown sort of unofficial
symbol this is the Magic Roundabout you
just roundabouts roundabouts to make up
one mass here
holy crap is that a real thing it's
actually the portal to Hell oh yes it's
the portal preacher to drug the Terry
Pratchett's disease made a few
references to that the Lord I I don't
know chest across this you always get to
the airport
oh this is why you know he actually is
the source holy crap I could not I
should mention that for a brief period
my hometown this woman was linked with
Disneyland uh-huh someone had personal
letter to Disneyland but compared the
magic around how Jesus
please stop I King demamp hell is some
magical place man roundabouts are like
they're fun but they're not you know I
mean they're fun if you're a passenger
and they would potentially die yes right
as a passenger it's like we it's like
it's like a breathe it's like one of
those like what do you call those the
roulette wheel or whatever yeah spinning
around it's like I have like zero odds
of surviving what's your my number man
yes this this shows either they try to
make this into sort of like a hometown
pride kind of thing
oh god I don't ride I can't let a
mooncake as there as a student
they're probably entranced I'm like it
punt fun I bet shirt is hilarious I
think that is hilarious at least you're
wearing it like ironically I think I
lost my language was the laughs Tom
isn't she
that's great he's wearing it ironically
he's British Agito yeah well welcome
welcome back to have you ever tried to
drive through roundabouts yourself I
have there's roundabouts in DC like near
the Virginia Baltimore area and I didn't
like it
see I know I know I learned how to drive
in Rhode Island oh god I have to learn
how to literally how to drive like
starting off and driver's ed with
roundabouts but I no longer fear dad oh
if you have to drive with Massholes
you just know it is how you tell the
English posters here because we saw
conversations about roundabouts like so
how about those roundabouts
I think it's hilarious kind of
roundabout way and aw wah-wah-wah
yeah thanks um for the Magic Roundabout
there's a theme zone for it
no there's a there's a show was it like
a kids show sort of stop I think it
stopped
of course stereo magic you ever heard
that movie Dougal with the one that
they've redubbed with Chevy Chase
no okay there's this movie that they
read up with Chevy Chase and it's called
Dougal in America that's actually the
CGI adaptation of the magic RAM that
movie they redubbed for the American
market see in the UK that character was
originally voiced by Robbie Williams
we've got a Magic School Bus
and I've never seen the Magic Roundabout
so I can't say for sure if it's better
but the magic skills have any of you
ever been in a you know driving class
and then suddenly don't fear the reaper
comes on the radio that happened to me
and he turned off the radio hey Belson
no it was just playing in my head that
was just constantly going in my head
going for the Reaper oh wait she said
psychic instead of physics
I don't know physics is like a see
that's what one of your mistakes
yeah yo caption it is you just say it
just like one of my mistakes
yeah okay oh God
thing about series oh yeah hey what are
you got against white hot fuck its favor
man okay oh oh - can regional resigns so
all right quiet on set ready Malkin and
so sir start off four bags are like hey
blonde the block yeah it says it see I
like women as much you can sir like the
whole I need all my queries purely okay
okay bed that word now that's memory
you're two steps up and stuff I trust
you record in my home six or seven all
right y'all ready
hey and action
hey yeah yeah points advanced alien race
sure is easy to do hey let's go grab a
pint in Porto sounds good good we got a
little bit of your laughing up here so
when you say the long just got it up an
elegant okay ready enough and Angie hey
Malcolm you in there yeah boy this
advanced alien race sure is easy to dupe
hey let's go grab a pie de Portillo
sounds good I really believe what you
say oh yes oh like never piss off yeah
yeah
Texas Chainsaw Massacre oh nice let's go
it's going kind of slow though there's
actually a really cool perspective
oh my god that's our Malcolm here oh
yeah yes I like how Malcolm has an 80s
head all right so where's the black
paint oh no you were gonna bring that
kiss yes we figured we made you do it to
him therefore it's okay so I apply it
that way it works that way we're being
racially censored yes oh well we can
probably do except for a disorderly oh
yeah definitely
yeah it's recording okay okay what here
give you this okay so let's wait wait we
just took a picture of these two
together we're already thinking of sick
calmness we had a black and tan a black
and white black and blight of blacks it
lacks for Britain blacks which can be
Brit and black or just Britain like the
place black both were complete and the
real Matthew was showing through on the
top I'll do it again here about your
head United Kingdom of bel-air
I just imagine Matthew doing in West
Philadelphia
[Applause]
that's no proper Oh dudes like spaghetti
that'll be your catchphrase
I do like Sogeti ha ha ha ha all right
Holly we got to do the buddy-buddy like
you guys back-to-back give up good yeah
oh yeah Wonder Twins activate with your
froze combined I am captain black Britt
all right I think I think we milked this
wrong I think definitely yes yes he
really makes my shirt work are we
putting all of that in quotes like each
yes
each Roy oh it's perfect it's so perfect
yeah let me there you go please don't
dress for a second
yeah all right got that this is yeah
thank you
this is amazing this I don't how are you
yeah this one there is no getting out of
it I I think we're just guessing right
now tango
I'm Friday given I searched three stores
trying to find a week that we could do
for you we had all these fancies in
black rapper wig and everything and then
here's a little $4 census how about this
yeah it was like an 80s Heathcliff
character the garbage cancer oh yeah
Darrin he'd put yeah oh the cat the poem
is a poor man's car you can say I was
laughing Bromley at a poor man's goose
I was glass yeah of course you were
because your call you take our shitty
cartoon show during there's something
fancy I think it's the other way around
you take the fancy while you enjoy
second cartoon I wasn't familiar with
Kelsey show you would have had a blue
period
no thanks - performance is the Mel Blanc
after smoking a thousand packs of
cigarettes all his life years wardroom
Derek
Daffy Duck you're difficult no it was
Ruiz yeah that last decade was rough -
listen - yes Lian who is this so pretty
much we're gonna shoot the scene we kind
of the two teams to play both Malcolm
and Tamara yeah Tamara's going to be
shot in the lounge area like you're
going to be in the porphyrin so as what
this is so your boat you you're going to
be saying you get your feel smiley that
great evil Betty's mouth yes looking
good right um right now so this we're
going to be facing attorney and I say
ain't extraterrestrials really and it's
just way of doing what things don't they
you just go mm-hmm Tamron is a mirror
you two looking a bit more British than
usual and you're there with a smile you
say I don't know what you mean critic
I'll say yeah we're just our normal
American you wanna do slightly different
accents looter no I want just to be your
voice I would like the whole time like
there is no baby
Oh
so I don't know what you mean critic
yeah we just our normal American cells
sure you haven't taken filings because
that would just make too much sense oh
yes so however you say oh we have just
remembered because you're going to say
the same way as camera alright so
probably like it just oh yes but what it
is okay well go back to whatever we're
not alien things you were doing again
just is okay and then you just turn
around boy that way okay so here I'll
let you look dead oh I love how the
roundabout shirt is just coming through
yeah yeah
just to confirm this is amazing a really
whitewash that's the fucker they
rejected yeah oh that's great nobody
wanted to look in here and just see
themselves as white that's the funhouse
mirror that made America crazy Comerica
what's it taste like that's the beardo
Cosby's penthouse yeah I think we gotta
get those mirrors on show yeah yeah
first the sitcom and then the mirror
we'll have them here in the domino
spin-off show so if you're white do you
just appear invisible if you look you'll
be called near America great again I
like this word we're down to something
greater bitches over Oh joke is it oh it
is very much just call Matthew Malcolm
and man that's perfect
I was thinking like you know meltem
melter is never empty and M&M Tourister
mom alcaman memory that would be bad
I do like that - just my Malcolm yeah my
Malcolm what's gonna be Malcolm brain
but the work just didn't go together
calm wow wow wow all kept it up kind of
tension here today ok so this is going
to be this hanka be looking right at the
camera sort of like the everyday point
of view looking right at you got your
evil smile and I'm going to say let's
pick it up we're what's been up with you
- lady you look like a Canadian rap
group let's say it's it's time to begin
our hostile takeover and you just hold
this mom and I have these red eyes you
know shoot in the end stuff although I
can't like the perchick crunches do it
naturally anyway and then alien comes in
gets really big and you look up and go
oh bugger
and then Tara's in you tamra's can say
even though they're British stereotypes
its annual suspicions exploit so for
easy just hold the smile looking ride
the camera it's time to begin our
hostile takeover hold the smile I'll say
it I'll see hey Lane grows big you just
look up like oh bugger that's it okay so
Google I'll go a whole bag you look it
over why like frameless back yet cuz
we're gonna just go to have Tamra here
as well Matt him as Tamra race if you
want to just slightly right so oh right
it doesn't matter again sir yeah go
ahead
um yeah and you're right using opponent
okay yeah does look like some kind of
like euro singer from the early 2000s
like it for nearly 2000 really yeah see
you see I think like from see I want I
want to do turtle wrap yeah yeah
and a ravioli lady are we now he's mid
mid to late 80s Early 90s like you
wouldn't see this past 1990 okay uh yeah
Google maybe I felt like there was like
a weird resurgence in like 2000 2001 I
was like you're hipper than any of us
so trust you man speaking where was the
mum of you to wake me look like a
Canadian record it's time to begin a
hostile takeover bring red eyes oh my
god and the alien goes back oh bugger
perfect I'll try to March all right you
ready and speaking weird let's put up
with you two lately you look like a
Canadian rapper it's time to begin a
hostile takeover yeah it's a scary and
killing a figure oh bugger boys
bollocks um see Oh the here okay gonna
be really weird I'm just gonna get a
super tight close-up of you cleaned it
out you can see all around perfect 91
assessment oh no no I did
realize I think what if there's worse
than tourism I've been around yeah yeah
get the other gear just in case I think
this year I could my table right
yeah that's not something I did realize
I had Tamra I tan would come out this
way and you come out this way and I
realized the way I had them originally
their switch so I may have to switch
around what to see well I mean it's not
like you probably just sports I believe
Clinton earshot you're now with an
earshot citizen line fanfic writers
start your keyboard
Oh bye uh-huh yes finally a fetish for
me
oh I love those lobes
it's a good Carter which is I feel like
that really is a thing for some reason
dude if it didn't it probably everything
it's a day yeah it will be now ha ha ha
my god fine have we seen the creation of
a brand new fish yes sir go heartbreak
girl I'm a perverted life oh we are a
Spurling just very nice uh so we know
with his head he take his head office oh
how about get inside sure yeah okay
let's go you always bring the camera
with because we're gonna Portillo's we
guess II hope you liked it
oh yeah this will be your first time
having Portillo's yeah it's gonna be
awesome
okay yeah sorry yeah Wow don't yeah
we're just watching la story you ever
see that movie yeah yeah and yeah just
the probably offensive stereotype of
like the British weren't getting in
there just always doing a little bit of
filming Road but let's mate okay because
then Chevy Chase does it in European
vacation so that's a level that it Holly
story I like that movie yeah like it to
European vacations My Fair cousin Eric
Idle is character I thought so Oh
British experience where they were so
nice I'm just like weirding me out
what stop being so nice how are you
people I am filming from inside the car
we're on our way to Patil OHS yes I
remember Dilla's in a while since to be
really I just thought you know one day
when Tony came up not that nothing to do
with the full version P that uh that's a
which around America are going on later
I use for mercenaries don't didn't hear
any of that said something British takes
a woman there's a full report so she
could one bubble Portillo and he didn't
see her uh-huh but while traveling
trains he didn't American stories from
yeah he actually moved out here and
started this Chicago hot dog franchise
yeah yeah yo could happen I could I was
better that true man that was a trumpism
right there fancy word for lie yes he
sacrificed a lot
no my fare was uh yeah my dad started
from nothing I'm like sweet I start from
nothing to cuz my dad had children to
million dollars okay he had a small loan
of a million dollars my favorite yeah
small with a small loan of a million
dollars I'm I can't get a loan for ten
grand you shouldn't make when I came to
this country I only had two hundred
million and somehow I managed to build
an empire out of aid just scraping by
but my finger actually said that it was
like some sort of Q&A or something and
the guy just says it you do know that
many dollars is seen as a lot of money
to everybody right oh okay well I mean
we didn't see us a lot of money you know
but on the store business everything
oh my I really hope we are overhyping
Portillo's um probably our thumbs what's
the account okay it's over chicago-style
dogs and Italian beef sandwiches are
some of the things that you can only
kind of get in Chicago done right so
what is yeah oh that is a quicker way
but huh this way you're going you can
cut through there to get straight to the
shopping area but it just goes right or
this way well that one cuz yeah West Jim
sterling ah this was a mistake
Barney Barney how are you going where
you going
gotta beYOU guys let's do bit childish
oh you'll beat him easily I'll turn this
one god damn it his way was the better
way like eight cars just turned in here
well at least doug is wearing his seat
belt oh I see buddy oh so he's with it
so yeah I actually dug you uh you may
have found here Mike doesn't wear my
seat belt yes no Marie's on the back of
that can I have a t-shirt that has that
picture of Bill Maher yeah which is that
one oh is that like Royal Tenenbaums
memory which Bill Murray is that I think
that's just like a random picture bin
where he wears so like it's the one
where he doesn't give a shit yeah I know
that's very yeah yeah yeah but see that
you know what though that's like Eskimos
with the forty names for snow like
there's varying degrees of color
inoculation you know which one is it
lost in a translation I giving a shit
Royal Tenenbaums are giving me the
cinema ghostbusters then giving a shit
the O's Buster's remakes really not
giving a shit it don't be played for a
week
wow that's that's harsh
you
so the first thing you'll notice
immediately is the atmosphere yeah yeah
like I mean take a look around it's very
uh kind of 1920s themed yeah very jazzy
very eclectic
and each participation is unique to its
own like sort of decor
yeah record is the chocolate cake shake
you can tell it looks like a chocolate
cake shake it is amazing
berries nicotine's you slowly go up
there the secret is you just take a
milkshake and put a chocolate cake in it
and then blender you can feel your
arteries clogging I was literally
drinking this is why Isis hates exactly
that's what freedom tastes like my
friends all right sure
you've got to know the verdict too easy
is it right you got it with everything
on and over till the top to my Chicago
have to drag it through the garden I'm
surprised the size with people actually
applied to it
yeah anyway yes is a very big pick yeah
I know take me to get like a burger
so like
yeah but a whole big open yeah
Oh pickle
the a Chicago pretty much take a good
flavor and just punt you pretty much
know catch up you can never catch up no
no ketchup no no no no mustard only and
relish that if you ready to say fine and
kick your hands over good yeah fucking
go back to Wisconsin Michigan or Indiana
right you're watching closely Jim that
touch Leslie doesn't tell you honey
she quo like something either Simpson
you with them
anyone else one chocolate cake shake
I'll try Sam was it I'll try some there
you go Malcolm oh there you go the
little do people know I'm X to the
camera oh hold on a second hello okay um
okay uh we're gonna do one can I hear
weird to be doing a film brain
depressurizes right honey say told me to
do this I think he just wants to hurt
film rights because are you offended no
not really
that's good however once Russian goes
everybody and action hello just oh what
I really want
kind of like how you disagreed with me
sometime just you know hello hello hello
and and be a little bit more not point
you Valdez what your religion like
EurAsEC hello hello hello thank you know
it just like what's my this should be
very easy why is this not hot shit you
know cata thing okay okay ready or what
and action hello hello good let's do one
more make that line hello
it's evening make that like the third or
fourth okay I do you want to like a
hello like I have you now hello like
hello hello reduce music II for the way
you did that lasso it just hello okay um
okay right here oh yeah and action
hello hello hello hello
that's like you're practicing you're a
solo person can say hello like that and
it is Matthew oh yes
know anything about you it just be
safely to Omar you two were perfect
every time you pass by Tara always like
oh but you never hit my arm so that's my
fault I'm gonna try to keep the camera a
little more I would like this visa no
your you are fine huh I'm gonna be the
one that watches have your fantastic
don't change a thing you're amazing
amazing happy if you want to put a ring
on a citizen Matthew we're not getting
any young lady and actually hello behind
every British guy is run out of a shot
well what's your talk I have with me
well apparently Doug didn't write me
into this seat there was a long extended
love seems quite race assist if I don't
like I'm your own sensory I like to
voice out of ecology it was just like oh
draw me like one of your beautiful
french girls it was amazing
it's just amazing so now my in my pants
bullfights just see if you can take a
step closer you're gonna put them in our
chest oh yes oh this is gonna be
ah tikki I have a step back oh there
yeah is it all right Doug yeah that
should be really good
do you need me to do tamra's lenses ah
probably probably both now come in today
was I play fast
yes Malcolm swoons in terror yeah Oh
property there's the appropriate film
brain respect okay dance evening hammy
venture who turns a finder upside down I
tell you it was enough sight within how
the paper fall out you didn't have it in
ya that's Emma see it yeah that's it
that's it yeah yeah ant the vector just
yeah oh okay there we go
kinda sorta there we go dad escaped
rented no better director better huh
what sounds from Rob listen to us Oh
Simpson Jen and was it a badger student
enough about the principal it's wood oh
there I go okay yeah yeah okay no I'm
good
I don't think I was good before I think
is going on here but yeah welcome to
Mario's beauty boutique yeah we're gonna
make you hideous but these gorgeous
loves melons gradually becoming over
thing in the UK but it's a ya know you
don't do the trick or treat
Colleen does but it's not really it's
you know I'd never really got any triple
tree or anything like that
mmm like you can but it's not like you
know oh my god everybody
ya know we try to bring it early and
earlier we actually get help next door
it's nothing a first poshest yeah no no
no no even with Halloween Christmas is
still being sold they're still putting
it up into party stuff like that Home
Depot's got all their Christmas yeah no
they have only renders Halloween it's
crazy
well big stores like that I've got two
sizes we want and like yeah like if you
don't celebrate Halloween or like yeah
like my parents they don't really
celebrate Halloween you have to like put
it on your door if you're not
participating so that people don't ring
your door I didn't even
that's also an invitation just get your
housing yeah that apertures one oh that
was like a thing like not participate
Halloween oh I'm putting up it
yeah why do you put it on gotcha just
not answer the door yeah just cuz lights
off cuz people keeps them because people
keep coming like builder like it'll be
all night it's just like ding dong it is
like the birds like people some people
just like hind their basement shotguns
at the ready like no so and like yeah
like I like people stay in there for
like 5 minutes waiting samurai yeah just
turn the white zone just leave it like
three more houses and then five minutes
at you're ready yeah
it's just like it's all in our
neighborhood like no kids so you don't
really have any problem vandalism right
Doug you got the you got the thing in
the back no grab stuff
oh yeah no like I get my oh sorry I
might be getting really over here made
it uh-huh I can get the tag there you go
like that
yes I get my Halloween fixed by going
out to like the parties and the haunted
houses oh you're a furry you get like
every week oh yeah I do yeah you just up
already okay let me good is that a
minute for the candy oh yeah you have to
looks like a lamp sister no actually
looks like a shallot
well he's not done yet we're still we're
getting the blue in there and stuff yeah
Rosa oh my gosh it was serpent
unfashionable oh my gosh you guys it's
totally like me oh my god it's a mess oh
my god you guys looks totally
guys it is so cute this is other camera
oh my god this is just so good oh my god
yeah hmm
Oh Marty hey look what's amazing this
isn't you guys you work hard to get
impression so everybody yeah Malcolm's
Malcolm's is just oh oh no if they
vetted oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I'm on my
way
oh let's get to excuse it
sorry there was here what these is
really Shelley what oh wow oh Lt it's
like molting yeah we do need this
healthy though with me means everything
in the serious face yeah
it's a zoo oh do we Madison Oh one of
the kids yeah okay Jim pissed himself in
school and so therefore Billy did it to
make me not feel as bad will you take
some pictures of us well thank you is
this you want a photo or film uh photo
originally I was thinking like me we
should film like putting the water on
them like you know someone someone's
gonna be a yeah I'll watch it again I
got right now can you tell what yeah my
pictures you dad hahaha I did just be me
it just needs that me the pants she made
it sort of thing yeah
Jim let's just get this over with good I
don't think you could do that so did
your shell video you can do the other
side P me Jim
oh my god damn alright Dan move back a
bit odd alright white flight on the set
quando set you already yeah yeah this
serious yes fine
ready and action are we looking I'm
sorry
right here right here with a critic it
I'm sorry about the table yeah critic we
feed our pants
[Music]
alright nobody
I want our County y'all ready and action
critic we've peed our pants
[Music]